Speaker 1: speaking of court cases not going
particularly well, I have a very interesting
video of Infowars conspiracy theorist Alex Jones
in Connecticut. This is the latest Alex Jones
defamation trial. Remember, I interviewed the
plaintiff's attorney, Mark Bankston, not long ago
and he told us about this forthcoming case. This
is absolutely fantastic. Alex Jones flipped out
outside the courthouse yesterday saying the judge
isn't allowing me to argue that I'm innocent.
Now, that's not the way court works. And I'm
going to tell you why in a second. But take
a listen to what Alex Jones had to say.
Speaker 4: There's never before been done
in U.S. history. It's a struggle session right
out of communist China or South Africa. This is
serious tyranny. Regardless what you think about
me or how the media is here and over the years,
I have apologized for past things. I should
hurt people's feelings, but I wasn't the first
person to question Sandy Hook and I apologize
years ago. They have misrepresented what I said
and done during the whole industry of lawyers
around these families that have sued Remington
and won seven $3 million and won all these other
lawsuits. And they simply now are not just coming
for the Second Amendment, but the First Amendment.
This is a travesty of justice. And this judge is
a tyrant. This judge is ordering me to say that
I'm guilty and to say that I'm a liar. None of
that's true. I was not wrong about Sandy Hook on
purpose. I question it just like Jussie Smollett.
Just like WMD in Iraq. Just like Gulf of Tonkin.
There have been a lot of staged events in history
like WMD in Iraq, and I question every major event
that we see. And so I'm being put in a possible
position inside of this courthouse where I'm being
ordered to say I'm guilty. Has anybody ever heard
of someone being warned to say they're guilty?
Speaker 1: Okay. So Alex Jones, of course,
is not telling the truth. Here is what's
going on in this case. A default judgment
was already ordered last year against Alex Jones
because he refused to participate in discovery.
There was a defamation suit brought. Alex Jones
was ordered to participate in discovery. What
that means is you have to turn over information.
You have to turn over documents, evidence, etc..
If you don't do it. It's similar to just not
showing up to court. When you don't do it,
a default judgment is found against you. You
lose by default. It's sort of like you forfeit
and that's what took place. We are now in the
damages phase and Jones is trying to argue
his innocence. That is not for this phase
that is supposed to be done in the phase which
he forfeited the right to participate in because
he didn't participate in discovery. So he's saying
it's like communist China. It's like this, it's
like that. It's it's here. The judge is a tyrant.
These are the rules. He didn't
participate in discovery.
This was the case in the other defamation
suit as well. And now we are in the damages
phase. That's how the law works. And he claims
to be about law and order and how very quickly
that idea evaporates. Just absolutely pathetic.
This is going to be another fascinating trial